Oh doing another one I have a doctor's
appointment hello
okay the nominees for best costume
designer are wait that's it we can't
just skip right to the award you're
right you're right so much goes into
costume design um what should we say
well maybe we don't say it
maybe we're singing boots are made for
walking and that's just what they'll do
and one of these days these boots are
gonna walk all over me in ma oh yes Oh
devil with the blue dress blue dress
blue dress devil with the blue dress all
real
oh my god oh and Monroe Dietrich and
he is dancing with me
chica chief cheek-to-cheek in thunka
thunka
you can leave your paddle
[Applause]
here are the nominees for achievement in
costume design the irishman costume
designed by Sandy Powell and Christopher
Petersen Joe Joe rabbit costume design
by Maya
say sube Joker costume designed by Marc
bridges Little Women costume designed by
Jacqueline during once upon a time in
Hollywood costume designed by re n
Phillips and the Oscar goes to
Jacqueline Duran Little Women this is
the second Oscar in seventh nomination
for Jacqueline Derek
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank thank you to the Academy I'm
indebted to a lot of people to a
wonderful team to an amazing cast to
produce at Amy Pascal to my family who
enabled me to be a working mother and
first and last to Greta Gerwig she was
an inspiration to all of us
[Applause]
[Applause]